I am a classic millennial I'm highly
jaded and highly optimistic at the same
time I'm jaded because let's face it
were the generation that inherited all
the consequences of bad decisions from
previous generations climate change
wealth inequality broken health care and
to me businesses seem to be the biggest
culprits of these problems but I'm also
optimistic that businesses can be a
force for good and given the size of the
private sector businesses need to be
forces for good if we want real scale
change so how do we make businesses do
good of course as a millennial I said
I'm a problem solver I'm gifted and
special I'm going to single-handedly
solve this problem you're welcome guys
after college I went into investing to
understand and influence how businesses
make decisions in my job I came across a
lot of businesses and a lot of bad
decisions here's one well-known example
the BP oil spill in 2010 BP was facing a
delay in their drilling operations every
day of delay cost them 1 million dollars
under immense pressure they rushed a
launch of an oil rig in the Gulf of
Mexico the rig exploded causing the
largest oil spill in history killing 11
people and damaging our planet in ways
we still don't fully know today this was
costly for society but also costly for
BP to save 1 million dollars a day BP
cost its shareholders 100 billion
dollars
I call this nearsightedness focusing so
much on what's in front of you that
you're missing the bigger picture let me
ask you a question who here is near
so you have trouble seing what's far
from you but you can see clearly what's
close I am seriously nearsighted and we
all know how dangerous and frustrating
it is imagine one day you're outside
without your glasses or contacts you're
a disaster waiting to happen you might
be scanning the ground for something you
might trip on and suddenly a pole hits
your face traditional business thinking
is nearsighted focusing so much on
what's in front of you that you're
missing the bigger picture with this
realization I search for a better way to
invest in and support businesses that is
putting on a pair of glasses that would
help me see more clearly and more
comprehensively investing with and
impact lens by impact lens I mean asking
yourself more questions before you make
decisions is this truly the best
decision for the long-term
sustainability of the company can I do
this in a way that does good or reduce
harm for society just imagine if someone
at BP had asked those questions the
impact lens is for everyone not just
impact investors or social entrepreneurs
it doesn't mean making bad decisions to
do good it means making better decisions
to do good and do well your ears better
be perking up because I'm telling you
the impact lens can make you more money
with every business and investment
decision you have to evaluate two things
opportunities and risks the impact lens
can help you see both new opportunities
and new risks you might not be seeing I
want to tell you two stories to show you
what I mean the first story is about
opportunities Jon scherhorn was a former
English squash player and an
entrepreneur looking for new
opportunities as an athlete he noticed
that all gyms in the UK were located in
wealthy metropolitan areas charging high
prices
this made him think a low-cost gym
concept targeting lower-income markets
could do a lot of good and be really
successful so he wrote a business plan
and then he sought out funding but
investor after investor rejected him it
wouldn't work they said if Flor income
markets were so attractive gyms would
already be there then one day he found a
match bridges an impact investment fund
had also concluded that low costumes
would be an attractive opportunity to
deliver financial returns and societal
impact together treehorn and bridges
incubated the gym group a chain of
twenty four seven low-cost gyms targeted
at lower income markets the gym group
was a massive success in 2015 the
company IPO at a valuation of 380
million dollars almost six times the
original investment private equity funds
typically target two to three times
today the gym group has more than 130
germs and 660 thousand members now while
the gym space was already crowded no one
had thought lower income markets for an
attractive opportunity sridhara and
bridges saw this opportunity because
they had their impact lenses on so
whether you want to start run or invest
in businesses how can you use the impact
lens to see opportunities you might not
be seeing the impact lens also helps you
see hidden risks Paul Polman became the
CEO of Unilever in 2009 pullman was a
strong believer in doing well by doing
good with his impact lens on he saw
opportunities to grow in emerging
markets he also saw a risk that no one
was talking about climate change Pullman
thought climate change was the single
biggest threat to Unilever and no
investor had ever asked him a question
about it Pullman declared
in ten years I'm going to double
profitability while cutting
environmental footprint in half becoming
more environmentally sustainable was
going to cut costs and reduce risks he
said people thought he was crazy the
results eight years of positive growth
twice the rate of Unilever competitors
total shareholder return of nearly three
hundred percent in that time period
returns and profits are up but even more
importantly long term risks are down
Unilever is better prepared for climate
change than any of its competitors now
climate change is just one example of a
societal issue threatening corporate
welfare global poverty employees skills
gaps political and social instability
nearsighted businesses will say these
are not my problems but if we put our
impact lenses on we can see that these
issues will hit businesses before they
know it now I'm not saying that every
decision is going to be a win-win but
win-win situations are out there and we
absolutely have to chase every single
one of them john treehorn and Paul
Polman are two pioneers in this movement
slowly others are catching up just last
year the CEO of the C of Blackrock Larry
Fink said in a statement to CEOs to
prosper over time every business must
not only deliver financial performance
but also show how it makes a positive
contribution to society what we need are
more business leaders and institutional
investors with their impact lenses on we
also need personal investors and
consumers demanding for more impact from
businesses we Millennials have to take
that charge we're known as the
generation of FOMO fear of missing out
well guess what we're missing out big
time because we're not using the impact
lens in our business thinking we're also
known as a generation of self
entitlement well I think we are entitled
to a better future where businesses can
be part of the solution and not just the
problem we're a fresh set of lenses can
help us see the world in a better light
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]